en vídeos anteriores hablamos de como
una corriente que pasa por un alambre
puede inducir un campo magnético
un campo magnético
pero en este vídeo vamos a hablar de
cómo puede suceder lo opuesto como un
cambio en el flujo magnético puede
afectar o inducir una corriente en un
circuito de alambre así que pasaremos de
un cambio en flujo magnético cambio en
flujo magnético a través de un circuito
y vamos a ver cómo esto nos genera una
corriente
inducida nos genera una corriente
inducida
esto que ven acá es mi intento por
dibujar un campo magnético estas son las
líneas del campo magnético aunque no se
ven como líneas ya que éstas están
dibujadas como si salieran de la
pantalla se están moviendo hacia ustedes
pueden ver esto como las puntas de las
flechas que indican la dirección del
campo hay diferentes formas de dibujar
campos magnéticos podemos usar líneas
como éstas para expresar el campo
magnético también podemos usar vectores
y cuando usamos líneas de campo
magnético la densidad de estas líneas
nos indica qué tan fuerte es el campo
magnético en esa parte si vemos a la
derecha aquí hay poca densidad de líneas
al menos comparadas con la cantidad de
líneas que se encuentran del lado
izquierdo así que el lado izquierdo
tiene un campo magnético más fuerte en
comparación con el lado derecho de este
campo magnético si dibujaremos el campo
magnético con vectores tendríamos que
poner flechas más grandes aquí en
comparación de los vectores que dibujar
y amos del lado derecho vamos a dibujar
aquí un circuito
conductor de alambre por ejemplo
entonces tengo mi circuito de alambre
por aquí
si yo lo coloco aquí y permanece sin
cambios no lo muevo ni nada y este campo
magnético tampoco cambia pues voy a
tener cierto flujo que pasa a través de
esta superficie que se forma con el
circuito y si no están familiarizados
con el término de flujo magnético los
invito a que vean el vídeo de este tema
de flujo magnético si yo tuviera ese
circuito estacionario en este campo
magnético no va a suceder nada pero
podría inducir una corriente si cambio
el flujo magnético que está pasando por
esta superficie por ejemplo ahorita el
campo magnético está señalando hacia
afuera de la pantalla si yo quisiera
hacerlo más fuerte en la dirección que
apunta afuera de la pantalla una forma
de pensar en esto es que si yo mostrar
el cambio en el campo magnético o en el
flujo para que se vuelva más fuerte en
la dirección hacia afuera
aquí lo estoy dibujando más grande
quizás podríamos decir que estas cosas
aquí se vuelven más densas en la
dirección hacia afuera
esto va a provocar una corriente
inducida y la corriente inducida va a ir
en esta dirección
esta corriente va a ir en sentido
horario y esto se debe a que el cambio
en el flujo magnético induce un voltaje
induce una fuerza electromotriz que va a
ocasionar este flujo de corriente hay
otras maneras de cambiar el flujo
magnético
si yo disminuyera el campo magnético en
la dirección hacia afuera o en otras
palabras el cambio en el flujo magnético
fuera hacia adentro la corriente iría en
la otra dirección aquí la clave es el
cambio en el flujo magnético que pasa a
través de esta superficie definida por
este circuito no voy a tener una
corriente inducida si mi campo magnético
es estacionario y no cambió nada en el
circuito o en forma pero en el momento
en el que cambio el flujo magnético aquí
voy a inducir una corriente también en
lugar de cambiar el flujo magnético en
lugar de cambiar el campo magnético
puedo mover mi circuito de alambre
la dirección y al moverlo el flujo que
pasa a través de esta superficie o que
podríamos decir que sale de esa
superficie va a aumentar ya que si lo
muevo a la izquierda el flujo magnético
va a ser más denso y más fuerte por lo
que va a aumentar el flujo que pasa a
través de esta superficie si lo movemos
hacia acá también tendremos una
corriente inducida ahora si lo viéramos
en sentido opuesto si estuviera del lado
izquierdo y lo viéramos hacia la derecha
también se induciría una corriente pero
ya que el flujo va a disminuir la
corriente va a ir en la dirección
opuesta hay otras maneras de cambiar el
flujo por ejemplo cambiando el área que
está contenida por este circuito no sé a
lo mejor si estuviera hecho de algún
alambre que pudiera estirarse si
nosotros pudiéramos incrementar y
permítanme dibujarlo de esta manera si
pudiéramos estirar este alambre para que
aumente el área que contiene
esto ocasionaría que el flujo que va
hacia fuera de la pantalla aumente y
esto también nos va a provocar una
corriente inducida y toda esta idea de
que un cambio en el flujo magnético
induce una corriente es la esencia que
veremos más en detalle en futuros vídeos
de la ley de faraday ley de faraday y
vamos a cuantificar esto más en futuros
vídeos pero es la noción de que si yo
tengo un circuito de alambre y tengo un
cambio en el flujo magnético que pasa a
través del área definida por este
circuito me va a inducir una corriente
en este circuito